today we're going to go on a bit of a
winding journey into Circle geometry now
I love the topic of circle geometry but
it's a little bit of a shame Circle
geometry no longer features really in a
deep way throughout the New South Wales
mathematics syllabus that I teach there
used to be in the advanced uh course a
lot of deductive geometry in plain
shapes which led to a lot of circle
geometry in the extension one course
both of which are not really part of the
syllabus anymore however they haven't
disappeared entirely because up in
extension 2 a lot of the work that we do
in complex numbers on the argand diagram
is actually it actually produces circles
and therefore to understand the geometry
there you end up doing Circle geometry
so it kind of is snuck in as a little
bit of assumed knowledge and the thing
that I love about it even if you don't
have to do extension 2 is that it's a
fantastic emblem or embodiment of the
reasoning that is right at the heart of
the mathematics discipline and the
mathematics courses that I I teach and
my students learn so what I want to do
is I actually want to just explore and
unpack a single theorem a single
property that applies to Circle geometry
and I want to kind of take you on a
little bit of a journey of proving it
but also proving something a bit a bit
unusual about it well at least it was
unusual to me after teaching for 15
years I was kind of surprised this is
the first time I encountered it so
without giving more Preamble let me tell
you about the particular property that
I'm interested in it's about what we
call the angle in a semicircle so if you
take any Circle and you draw any
diameter so you can see I've already
marked the center of this circle so if I
draw a chord that passes through that
Center it'll be at diameter so if I say
for example
place a let's get a straight line here
place a chord right through the center
like so okay fantastic so this is a
diameter now if I then take this
diameter and use its ends like if I call
this diameter diameter a b and then I've
got the the center of the circle o there
okay
if I pick any other point on the circle
anywhere on the circumference I should
say say for instance a point like say
here
then if I join up an angle from a to
that point
and then go from B to that point and
let's call this new Point P one of the
things you'll notice and if you've drawn
a circle yourself at home and you've
picked some arbitrary diameter a b and
some arbitrary Point p i could put this
anywhere that I liked you would actually
show that you always get a right angle
and in fact a kind of nice neat
illustration for this let me see if I
can actually do it all in one go if I
delete my constructions in the manner
that I made them and just replace them
with this triangle ABP that I've created
here
if I just do the triangle from the
beginning let's see I think that's
pretty good let's get those spots there
okay what I've got now is this ABP
triangle and if I just leave a and b fix
but move P around you can see what I've
got here as long as I move piece
somewhere along the circumference of the
circle and stay on there can you see
wherever you go you're going to get that
right angle I can move it even over to
the other side I mean the symmetry of
the circle probably tells you you're
always going to get something like that
right so this this sort of uh geometric
feature that we notice here because it
is true wherever p is on the
circumference one of the ways that we
can phrase this is that the angle in a
semicircle because a b the diameter
creates well create two semicircles but
the angle in the semicircle in this case
a p b
it's always going to be 90 degrees it's
always going to be a right angle now
this is kind of cute it's kind of lovely
I I think it's it's uh really nice
because of Simplicity and also it's
slightly surprising but what another
feature that's really nice about it is
it's very easy to prove and when I have
taught this many times in the past it's
always essential not just to give a
property but to say well how do I know
that that property actually is true I
mean it kind of looks like it and you
can draw as many circles and diameters
and angles in the semicircle that you
like and you'll verify this but one of
the things that sets apart mathematics
is that giving examples even lots and
lots millions of examples is not
sufficient to constitute a mathematical
proof what we look for is a deductive
argument we want to see the logic that
proves to us why it is the case now when
I've taught this in the past I have
pretty much always done a version of the
proof that I'm about to show you now and
it's it's pretty straightforward and and
simple and brief which is why I've used
it so frequently and the way to prove
that this angle here APB is always going
to be right angled just relies on a few
basic features of a circle so let's just
suppose we rewind a little bit we've
created the diameter a b and we've
chosen a point p and we want to know
what is that angle there like what is
this equal to if I didn't already know
that it was 90 degrees how could I
evaluate it well what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to put in a a small
construction and then do some
calculation with the angles some um some
not even calculation really a bit of
manipulation of the angles and you'll
see why it must be true that APB is
Right angled here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to start by adding in this
radius here o p the radius op is
valuable because it's not the only
radius that I have in this diagram right
because a b is a diameter that means
that O A that's also a radius because
it's from the center to the
circumference and so is OB so what I
have here is not just the big triangle
ABP I also have two smaller triangles
that are both isosceles because they
both have radii making up two of their
sides so here's an isosceles triangle
here and then there's another isosceles
triangle here now what this gives me is
a bunch of angles that I know are going
to be equal because equal sides are
opposite equal angles or in fact the
other way around because the thing that
I know is the equal signs so for
instance if I focus in on triangle a o p
you can see that this radius is opposite
this side this radius is opposite that
side so I've got a couple of angles that
are equal there let's just give them a
name let's call them both Alpha
like so and then I can make the same
argument let's switch over colors with
the other isosceles triangle right it's
going to be you might call them the base
angles of the triangle here and here
base angles is sort of helpful but also
also sort of unhelpful you can see these
two angles here don't look anywhere near
like the base which tends to be the
bottom of something because a triangle
of course can be oriented in any
direction that you like but by the same
token if I use a different label because
they're obviously not the same size or
they're not in this case anyway I'll
call this angle beta
and this angle beta as well
okay now I'm only a couple of short
steps away from proving what I wanted
which is the APB uh let's mark it in
here this angle here is the one that I'm
interested in I can show that it's equal
to 90 degrees in a fairly
straightforward way and maybe you can
see the logic before I get there I'm
just going to use the big triangle ABP
and think about its angle sum right so
if I look at all of the angles in
Triangle a BP I might as well mention
that in Triangle a b p what I've got is
there's an alpha up the top then I've
got the angle that I'm interested in and
I'll write that in Orange just to make
it very obvious it's a angle Alpha plus
beta that's the magnitude of it from uh
over here and here so I've added them
together
and then lastly I've got angle beta uh
that's going to all be equal to 180
degrees because that is what the angle
sum of a triangle is but just doing some
very simple uh collecting of like terms
on the left hand side you can see I've
got double Alpha plus beta because two
Alphas two meters that's equal to 180
and then just halving both sides gives
me the result that I was after Alpha
plus beta no matter where P happens to
be on the circumference is always going
to be that right angle of 90 degrees
so really nice okay and then what I
would normally do in classes I would
move on and we would learn one of the
many other Circle properties that are
part of this topic